bid you welcome if you were here so I'll
just take over that role for a moment
I'm looking forward to this discussion
this afternoon
and I want to share with you is it not
working I hear it is working yeah it is
working yeah
do you want me to speak a bit louder
I'll try if my voice can or closer to
the microphone if we were in a different
room in a different time I probably
might say winter is coming but not in
this temperature I want to share some
thoughts with you this afternoon about
why the European Commission decided to
draft a green deal and present it
yesterday I think we have to look the
facts into the face or to quote another
famous film to look beastie in the eye I
think science is clear the facts are
overwhelming we need to do everything we
can do to keep temperatures lower to
make sure that the rise of temperature
doesn't go beyond 1.5 degrees it's got
to be hard enough to get when I try to
explain that to my kids when they were
asking why you so insisted on that and
it's easy to explain it to kids when you
talk about what's happening to our
biodiversity that's very easy they
understand that and they want us to take
action but I also try to explain it in a
in a wider sense because of the
fundamental changes ongoing in our
society not just because of biodiversity
not just because of climate change also
because of the Industrial Revolution
we're in and how that shakes up all the
relationships across the globe between
peoples and nations and my point is this
just imagine that we would have some
astronomers looking into the sky and
seeing a comet and the trajectory of the
comet is
our planet and the comet will reach our
planet in 30 years time unless we do
something would we then happy having a
discussion about yeah but are we sure
about this oh do you think we can afford
this and I say to my kids what we see in
science is comparable to that Comet and
we need to mobilize all the creativity
we can muster in global society to make
sure that we have an answer
so that comet doesn't hit Earth and so
that we rebalance our relationship with
Mother Earth in a way that everybody can
have a decent life based on our values
on this planet that ladies and gentlemen
is the basis for the Green Deal this is
not just an answer to climate change it
is an answer to the many fold changes
that we are facing it is also a growth
strategy if we implement the policies
that we advocate in the Green Deal it
means rebooting our economy setting it
on a completely different footing
looking completely differently and how
we produce food and consume food looking
completely differently how we organize
mobility how we negotiate our
relationship with other parts of the
world how we create a better balance
between our cities and our rural areas
etc etc so we can only is it still not
working they can't in the outside would
want that to happen so what I'm trying
to say is this it is much more than us
trying to attain the Peris objectives it
is about understanding that we need to
be masters of our own fate and we can
only do that if we if we mobilize
governance at all levels local regional
national European
global and of all nature not no longer
just governance by governments but
governments governance by civil society
by everyone whose interest in this by
economic actors by trade unions by NGOs
by the scientific community by academia
allowed by the media etc that we all
understand we have a stake in this that
we do this in a way that is
intergenerational because I fear a lack
of understanding between generations if
we're not very careful and all of that
you can read in essence in the Green
Deal and I will be happy to go into all
the different elements of the Green Deal
but it is a comprehensive approach to
the issue it's not a blueprint it's not
a blueprint it's a road map
it offers avenues for us starting with
the assumption that we want to be or the
hopefully the commitment in law at some
point soon that we will be Europe a
climate neutral continent by 2050 and
then starting from that conclusion take
steps back until today and see what
needs to be done in intermediary steps
to get there and obviously one of the
first things we will need to do is make
a sound assessment of where we need to
be in 2030 and you know we have a lot of
scientific indications but I want to do
a very thorough impact assessment
between now and somewhere in the summer
next year so that we know exactly what
needs to be done to get us where we need
to be what I find most exciting and also
stimulating is that society is caught on
to the urgency of the matter over 90% of
Europeans see climate change as an
urgent matter that needs to be dealt
with and this is the best starting point
you can have as a politician if there's
so much support for taking measures in
such an area I also see but we will hear
a bit more
about this later on I also see a sea
change in the attitude of the private
sector only in a very few years well he
was on it for a longer time but most of
them only a very few years with a few
exceptions a few exceptions especially
in the fossil fuel industry but mostly
especially big corporations are on the
same line already understanding that
this paradigm shift is something they
have to embrace rather than try and slow
down the challenge in the private sector
ladies and gentlemen I think we'll be
with small and medium sized enterprises
because for them they don't do planning
over 20 30 or 40 years they think about
tomorrow or next year and how they keep
their employees employed now and we need
to make sure that we have a proposition
for them for instance making it easier
for them to refurbish housing to make
sure houses are isolated and our are
made a climate neutral or are fitted
with sustainable energy sources that
could be a huge engine for jobs and it
can be done the capital is there the
it's it's a matter of governance of
organizing it of mobilizing banks of
mobilizing intermediary agencies such as
chambers of commerce of creating nexuses
with bigger industries so that they
understand they need to take the smaller
medium-sized enterprises along on this
road and I think if we can show some
early successes if you can show this
works we can take away a lot of the fear
that people have for this change because
we live in a day and age and let me end
on that we live in a day and age where
for the first time in a long time
the dominant feeling is not my kids will
be better off than I was so let's put
our shoulders on them the dominant
feeling is I fear for the future of my
kids they will probably be worse off
than I am so what is it if that is the
dominant feeling what will you do what
will your attitude be if then a
politician comes along and tells you we
to change you will say change equals
loss and I don't want that so no change
and if we don't break that mold we will
be in the ironic or a really sad
situation that those people who will
suffer most if we don't address the
challenge of climate change the most
vulnerable people in our society can be
mobilized to be also the most vocal
people to stop us responding to the
challenge of climate change because they
believe there's nothing in it for them
other than loss so if we want this to
happen we have to make sure it is done
in a socially viable way so that people
see not just here but see that we leave
no one behind and then I believe we can
create we can mobilize societies to such
an extent that it will embrace the
opportunities that this new way of
looking at our society has to offer that
ladies and gentlemen is hopefully the
essence of the Green Deal when you look
at it more carefully and again it will
only happen you know Europe is
responsible for approximately 9% of
emissions so it only will be effective
on a global scale if we can convince our
other partners to take comparable
measures or to go along the same path
and we will do everything we can all our
efforts will be directed at that and
that's why we're here and that's why
we're working hard at this cop but by
the cop next year in Glasgow we have to
be ready we have to have our plans
worked out we have to be able to make a
proposition to the other parts of the
world that has a realistic perspective
of keeping us on track to fulfill the
Paris goals thank you very much for your
attention
[Applause]